Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
This will be my full video for the Echo series
Episodes one through five.
There are only five episodes.
There are bunch of Easter Eggs.
Obviously, it's meant to set up Daredevil Born Again
So I'll explain how it does that.
if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe To get all the videos.
We'll start seeing more footage
from Daredevil Born Again really soon too.
And I just did a Post-Credits scene video for that.
I'll link it at the end of this
and down to the description below
because it's all about setting up Daredevil born again.
Careful for spoilers
If you haven't seen the series yet,
we'll start at the beginning, work
our way through shop.
I saw I talked about Easter eggs, WTF moments.
Since I'm doing one video for the entire series, it's
going to be a little bit shorter
and I'm just going to cover the really big stuff
like the really big Easter eggs.
the reason why it's only five episodes
and it's not six like the typical longer
Marvel series
or like nine episodes of half hour series.
Marvel does.
is mostly because of the way they pace it.
Reportedly,
there was a deleted episode like a whole episode
that they shot
and then basically got rid of at the last minute.
I think what they probably did is they worked
in all the footage from Hawkeye during episode one.
Like that wasn't in the original cut of the series,
but there's a lot of footage from her time on Hawkeye
introducing her character because they basically
use episode one, or at least the first half of episode
one to tell her backstory in A big part of
that happened on the Hawkeye series in flashbacks.
So a lot of it is reused footage
from the Hawkeye Series, They created a brand new sub
brand called Marvel Spotlight that you saw in front
of all the episodes with a whole new intro logo
that's based on the Marvel Spotlight Comics, where
they would do like ghostwriter stories that were meant
to be one offs that you didn't need to know everything
that was going on in the main continuity.
Just understand that one story.
But it is meant to be the first of many TV-MA series.
So there is hope that they do more hardcore
adult themed series.
it's also notable because it's Marvel's
first solo series for a character who is as well,
not the first disabled character they've ever done
because Daredevil, probably a much more famous
character,
also disabled Charlie Cox said that during episode one,
when Daredevil was fighting Echo during the flashbacks,
one of the big issues that he rose in
the production was how they would communicate
because Daredevil is blind and Echo is deaf.
So how did they communicate in the cheat?
Answer to that like the workaround to that
is that Daredevil can actually read her body language
using his ability.
even though he can't see with his eyes
in the traditional way.
He has a sort of daredevil type of sight,
like a radar type of sight.
so he can read her body language,
all recuse her stances in sense.
What's coming from her most of the series is meant
to be five, six months after the events of the Hawkeye
Series, enough time for Kingpin to have recovered
so that he can walk around with a little eyepatch on.
but throughout the series,
there are many flashbacks to much earlier
in the timeline to her childhood
and to ancient history.
Episode one was titled Chop.
That's a reference
to the very first member of the Choctaw Nation.
They opened the episode with an MCU version
of the Choctaws origin story myth in real life,
like this whole concept of the mound
is part of the real life Choctaws origin story myth.
what they done for the MCU version
though, is they make it a little more cosmic.
so what they're saying
is that her ancestors were actually cosmic
beings living in another dimension,
like a little pocket dimension here.
That was destroyed,
throwing them into the normal MCU dimension
where they were transformed into humans,
but retaining some of their cosmic power.
Notice when you see them drinking from the pool,
you see the spiral.
It's like the spiral galaxy.
That's because they're in a higher dimension
when this is happening.
Like this is meant to look like the Milky Way galaxy.
when she drinks in the pool, you can see her literally
scooping up a galaxy and consuming it.
without more context.
My assumption is the reason why this pocket
dimension of theirs was destroyed
and they had to flee to the main MCU dimension.
Was price something to do with the King multiverse,
where all of the incursions
that are happening in the lead up to Avengers
five, in Avengers, six secret wars.
just because that's pretty much
where all this cosmic stuff is headed in the MCU.
So there's like a root cause for chaos
happening in the MCU in a cosmic sense.
Right now, it has something to do with secret wars
and all the different universes collapsing.
Right.
Now, in the MCU, slowly, Doctor Strange is going around
watching all of these incursions, basically
dimensions, other universes all slowly collapsing,
colliding with each other until there's nothing left.
But because of the Kang Multiverse.
War is happening across the timeline.
This is happening to them at the beginning
of the timeline, like the very beginning of time
in the MCU, right after the Big Bang,
you probably recognize the actress Here is Julia Jones.
She was in Twilight.
She was in The Mandalorian season one.
She's done a bunch of other stuff.
she's meant to be the direct
ancestor of Echo in present day,
which is why she keeps having the visions of her
and the other female members of her family line.
They basically explain that she passes her cosmic
abilities on biologically through her genetic line.
essentially a big part of the series
is Echo starts to have these visions
more and more
is her unlocking these abilities within her.
The same way that Peter Quill unlocks his
celestial powers when he's near ego, the living planet.
I don't think that makes Echo a celestial.
I think she's something a little bit different.
Her powers are more on the level of, say,
like Captain America.
so it's not like she's part God or anything like that.
She's not that powerful.
we start getting flashbacks to her childhood
with her cousin, who she also felt like was her sister.
We meet more of her family.
We meet her mother,
who figures in heavily to the entire series.
the other really important thing
that you probably notice, too,
is that the person who's played
the adult version of her cousin Bonnie, is Devery
Jacobs, who also plays Kahhori during What If season two.
She'll be back during what if season three
But she's like a really big Native American cosmic
character now powered up by the Tesseract,
super powerful, probably eventually
going to show up in live action at some point.
But for those of you that are wondering,
Kahhori is not meant to be
the same character is either Echo or Bonnie here.
They're like completely different characters.
It is the coincidence that this actress
is playing this other person in real life.
she's already talked about playing Kahhori in real life.
And I'm sure Kevin Feige would let her come back
as the live action version of that character
in something like Secret Wars.
But I don't think this a plan right now
in the next couple of years.
Like if she does come back in live action,
Kahhori would be in secret wars.
we start to see the birds showing up.
The bird itself
is meant to be a representation of her ancestors.
Like her ancestors spirit
who acts as a herald for danger, warning her
when bad things are about to happen.
And it happens
throughout their entire family's history.
her mother also explains to her
that the original Choctaw also trained those birds
as a sort of early warning detection system
that would bang on trees when trouble was on the way.
so in present day,
they also want you to think that the bird is basically
her mother's spirit
who's come back to warn her as an adult.
they don't really get into her father's back story
too much.
Just the idea that he's involved in something shady on
the reservation has something to do with Kingpin.
And that's how he got the job
with Kingpin through Henry the Tracksuit Brothers
in how they wound up in New York City
when Maya was a little girl.
Then they jump to all the flashbacks
that we saw in the Hawkeye series.
This is basically all reused footage from Hawkeye.
we see the scene where he gets ready to take her for
ice cream because her father goes on a job for Kingpin.
They show us the ice cream scene
a couple of episodes later
where Kingpin
basically beats the life out of the ice cream vendor.
It was in all the trailers Maya watches.
It is not bothered by it in it gives kingpin pause
like he gets this idea in his head, like,
you're kind of like me.
And he takes her on
is sort of like a surrogate daughter.
if it wasn't clear, yes,
he is manipulating her throughout her
entire life, just kind of pushing her around,
making her do whatever he wants her to do.
But but he does care for her in his very toxic
kind of way.
Notice all the stories that her father told her
about dragons living in a different world.
If they were able to come into our world
like our dimension, they would be much more powerful.
That's a reference
to a lot of things we saw in like the Sheng Shi movie,
things that were actually real in the MCU.
Like we've actually seen dragons flying around.
when he tells her that she needs to learn to jump
between two worlds.
It's a reference
to the cosmic side of her origin story.
Like it's foreshadowing for her,
unlocking her powers and dealing with her
cosmic backstory, but also learning to balance
both sides of her life, her Choctaw
life, like her true heritage and her life with kingpin,
very violent back story.
They jump forward in the timeline.
She sees her father killed by Hawkeye in his ronin
gear, then finds out eventually
that Kingpin is the person that tipped Hawkeye off
and he killed his father.
So Kingpin was essentially trying
to get rid of her father, using Hawkeye to do it.
this is actually meant to be an Easter egg
for Echo's back story.
In the comics, only Daredevil was swapped for Hawkeye
in the MCU version.
in the comics.
Kingpin killed her father,
then lied to her when she was younger, telling her
that Daredevil killed
him, trained her to be his weapon,
and then set her against Daredevil,
just hoping that she would kill Daredevil for him.
basically in the MCU, Kingpin did the exact same thing.
But with Hawkeye.
but it takes a long time for that to happen.
And remember,
her father was killed during the five year time jump.
So that's happening while everybody has been stabbed
confirming the kingpin was not snapped.
that's probably one of the ways
he was able to seize power in New York City
and become the boss of bosses again.
they already confirmed that everything from the Marvel
Netflix series, all of them are canon to the MCU.
So everything that happened on Daredevil Season three
when he was arrested, when he almost
wound up running for mayor,
but then got arrested, that's Canon.
so at some point he had to rebuild his power base.
That probably happened during the five year time jump.
we see her stealing the bike, then turning it on the
cops, basically just an act of aggression on her part.
She's just acting out.
Kingpin shows up to pull her out of police custody.
Notice that the police are afraid of him.
this is still during the five year time jump.
So basically the cops even now are letting Kingpin
do whatever he wants to do.
this is where he starts to give her actual jobs
to do within his organization, basically
going and killing people,
beating the crap out of people,
to hope that it'll get the aggression out of her system
The first job he actually sends
her on is the one that we saw on all the trailers where
she knocks around all the other rival organization
that are trying to pull a fast one on Kingpin.
They explain that when this is happening,
she's supposed to be 18,
19 years old, basically still a teenager.
She's never killed anyone.
So when she kills this dude in the middle of this fight
is the first time she's ever done this.
is that.
It's meant to be transformative,
kind of in a toxic way for her.
And then she runs into Daredevil,
who shows up because he was casing the joint,
saying that they ruined his chances.
He was probably trying
to trace these men back to Kingpin.
And because they killed all of them,
he can't do that now.
So that's why Daredevil was pissed at her.
He basically kicks her ass and notice that his red
costume is meant to be exactly the same red costume
that he wore during the Daredevil Netflix series
that's because this is taking place during the five
year time jump long before the events of She-Hulk,
before he gets that yellow and red costume.
notice King thing.
Congratulates her like she lasted longer than any of
the other men under his organization against Daredevil.
But she still got her ass kicked.
she winds up taking command of the tracksuit
bros for kingpin.
And just a bunch of years go by.
We see a flashback to the events of the Hawkeye series
after the five year time's up after everybody's
come back, her killing a whole bunch of people
for Kingpin, just getting rid of anybody
that he wants to get rid of.
Then we see the end of the Hawkeye series
after she finally confronts Kingpin with the truth
about killing her father and she takes off on the run
in about five, six months go by
and we see her at the gas station she's on her way back
to the Choctaw Nation to hide out from Kingpin's men.
Anybody else that wants to come after her,
basically retaliate against her.
They call her, quote unquote, the King killer
because she thinks
she thinks that she killed Kingpin,
even though we know that's not true.
there's a bounty on her head and basically everybody's
trying to kill her, track her down
so they can collect on it.
But what I think actually happened
is the kingpin himself
put the bounty on his head to try and get her back.
That's probably why the stipulation of the bounty
was being turned in alive, not dead or alive.
the minute she gets back to the reservation,
she grew up and she starts having visions of choppa
in her ancestors, she begins to slowly unlock her
powers When she runs into her cousin biscuits Again.
The funny thing about biscuits, it's
not really an Easter egg,
but almost seems like everybody on
this show wants to protect biscuits.
Like he's the most important character
on that reservation.
Like anytime anything bad happens, everyone's
always worried about biscuits first, like his biscuits.
Okay, something bad is going to happen to him
if it goes, stays around his dog's name is Billy Jack.
That is an Easter egg in real life
for the movie about a mixed race
Native American who defends his school
against an angry mob of townspeople.
It's a classic movie if you haven't seen it,
we find out that her father's old partner in crime,
Henry runs the skate rink.
They even have a Trump joke.
Make America skate again, Vicky turns out to be a plant
working in Kingpin's organization,
but is super low on the totem pole.
And he just working there looking for Eko,
trying to work his way up the ladder by turning her in.
the way they explain it,
though, Kingpin owns a shipping organization amongst
many other organizations, probably shipping
just happens to be one of his businesses.
and in this part of Oklahoma, Henry
just runs this part of the operation.
Suzanne, of like an underboss for kingpin
in this part of the country
that, explains how her father originally got the job
with Kingpin in the Tracksuit Bro's.
when she starts talking to Henry about
maybe it being time for a queen, for a brief second,
it sounds like she wants to take over Kingpin's
organization, but that just feels insurmountable.
Like it is an enormous organization with way more
powerful bosses
that she would have to kill before that could happen.
obviously, by the end of the series,
that doesn't wind up happening.
They kind of wind up dropping that plot point like she
seems like she backs off of that idea pretty quickly.
then they reveal the kingpin is now awake.
It seems like he's been awake,
like he's been on the edge of death for a while,
for a couple of months
recuperating in this hospital bed.
is meant to be an Easter egg from the comics.
Basically the same thing played out
the same way in the comics.
Eko winds up learning the truth.
The kingpin was responsible for her father's
death, tries to kill him,
but only wounds him in the eye in the Daredevil comics.
When Kingpin came back after this moment,
he lost temporary use of both of his eyes,
not just one
it was meant to be ironic because Daredevil is blind.
I think the way that you explain him surviving this way
and not losing his eye, like it's just damage
he didn't lose the eye itself
is that she wasn't actually trying to kill like either
she backed off
or he dodged just enough for it to graze his head.
so either he's super quick or she's a bad shot.
But I guess it's a little bit of both.
Episode two was called Low Walk.
That's echoes
other ancestor that we see in the 1200s in Alabama.
All the Choctaw tribes here at the beginning
in this opening scene are playing stickball,
which is one of the Choctaw traditional sports
that they used to play during this era.
this is actually meant to be a thing
based on real life history.
but in the context of the episode,
the stakes of this game are
that the losing tribe
actually gets banished from these lands.
so it's not like they're playing just for fun.
Luke has a vision of their ancestor Chop,
just like Echo does,
and also gains a quick power up
Captain America style, helping her win the game.
This ends up happening to several people in Echo's
ancestral
line, basically foreshadowing it
happening to her at the finale.
notice inside Scully's pawn shop here.
Biscuits. References.
Madripoor Seeing a lot of knockoff material gets made
there, imported by big companies on the cheap.
Madripoor is that lawless island from the comics
that Sharon Carter Power
Broker works from inside the MCU
they visited during Falcon and Winter Soldier.
is also a big location in the Wolverine Comics, too.
So big X-Men, Easter Egg there too.
we learned a little bit more about kingpin
shipping operation.
It just seems like he uses it to ship
all kinds of shady stuff.
But in this particular case, like in these episodes,
it's weapons mostly that he's shipping,
after she plants the bomb,
she gets another vision of chopper helping free
herself, getting a quick power up back in New York,
the Zane character is the local boss
working under Kingpin, but I think he's meant
to be part of the Black Knight cartel.
Like you see the knife tattoo on some of their necks.
There are another organization from the Bullseye
Comics, part of the idea you have to remember is
the kingpin is boss, the bosses bosses like he controls
a lot of other crime families around New York City.
the explosive goes off.
Then obviously,
they come back to Choctaw Nation looking for revenge,
kind of tracing down
who could have done this because of Vickie.
They find out about Echo
episode three was called Took Load.
That's a reference to Echo's ancestor from the 1800s.
They start with the old timey backstory,
like someone is watching this highlight reel
that was actually taken during the 1800s.
and it's all about the creation of the Light Horseman,
a type of internal police force,
Native
American tribes would create to police their own lands.
We see Echo's ancestor in her visions,
who became a light horseman is meant to foreshadow
echo trying to defend against all the different men
who come for her later in the episode at this
gate ring they're couple funny Easter eggs in the back
but like just funny moments.
The things that you pick up if you watch the episode
a couple of times, like one of the women
here is watching a YouTube
channel called Militia Mommies.
Obviously, the phone call
that Zane gets is from Kingpin staying his hand
like he's the one that orders them to cancel the hit
and then heads the reservation himself
to try and bring Echo back
arriving in person at the end of the episode
and this is meant to be the first time
she's seen him since the events of Hawkeye.
So she thought that she killed him,
which is why she's so taken aback.
episode four was called Tallulah,
which is a reference to Echo's mother.
That was her name.
they show the flashback from the trailers
when Kingpin took her to get ice cream.
The events that we saw basically in the trailer looking
had that entire scene in the trailers.
they went have jumping forward in the timeline to that
same five year time jump when she's still a teenager
getting ready to take over the tracksuit burrows
and he's just finished teaching her everything.
He wanted to teach her about his criminal empire.
kills the sign language translator
he'd been using to speak with her R.I.P.
and later reveals that he actually created
a translation device using technology.
All this rather than just taking the time
to learn sign language himself.
This is like a very kingpin way
of solving a simple problem, like solving a problem
in the most complicated way possible.
he probably spent a fortune
to accomplish this rather than just
take a little bit of time
to actually learn sign language the old fashioned way.
biscuits, winds up, making a Lion King reference.
Then her grandmother starts to make her new super suit
based on Choctaw traditions.
Her family's traditions Then Kingpin shows her
his father's hammer that he'd used to kill him,
that he'd been keeping this entire time
since he was a young boy
in tells you the truth about what happened,
and challenges her to do the same thing.
Like I killed my father to free myself
from all the pain that he was causing.
You do the same thing now, challenging her to kill him,
which obviously she doesn't like.
She actually genuinely tries to help him.
Eventually, by the end of the series.
a big part of the series was her generally learning
to process everything bad that had happened in her life
and make peace with it in a way
that kingpin didn't seem like he was able to do
Episode five was titled Maya, which is obviously Echo's
name It's meant to be the culmination
of her internal journey of her family,
her history, her cosmic ancestors, her cosmic powers.
they start with the flashback with her in her mother
in the bird is essentially meant to be her ancestor.
But we do see that
her mother is able to use cosmic powers to heal it.
So when they reference her mother being a healer,
it wasn't just a metaphor.
Like she wasn't just a regular medic.
Suzanne, actually running around
using her cosmic powers to heal people.
Notice later, after she takes off,
she's at a rocks on gas station.
They're a natural resources company in the MCU.
Also featured heavily in the comics.
they've been featured in a bunch of Marvel movies,
a bunch of Marvel
TV series all over the place
we've never seen their CEO.
But in the comics,
their CEO is actually a man who turns into a minotaur.
He's a big part of the Thor comics Generally,
they're meant to be a pretty evil company.
I know there'll be a bunch of questions
about all the visions she has of her mother,
so when she returns home, she actually literally sees
her mother is meant to be a hallucination.
I think this actually gets into
the whole concept of moon night in life after death.
Like your consciousness
just travels to another dimension after you die.
in her mother's spirit,
which is communicating with her from the dimension
that their people go to, the Choctaw people
go to after they die.
they don't really take the time in the series
to actually explain what the name of this other
dimension is, but assume it just based on real life
Choctaw traditions, like during Moon Night, moon night.
Because he has the contract with conch,
you goes to the Egyptian afterlife, which is the Duart.
then they have the big powwow finale.
She winds up rejecting Kingpin
like she refuses to go back with him and be like him.
taps into her ancestors cosmic power, activating
the same power in her grandmother and her cousin.
another little wrinkle in the power there, too.
Like she passes it
to the other female members in her line.
I don't think the power works like this
for all the women in the Choctaw tribe.
Just the members who can directly trace their lineage
to this chief, a character,
Henry in Biscuits, take out the rest of the Kingpin's
henchmen while the women use their powers
to stop kingpin the others inside the barn remember
that basically gives them a power up on the level
of something like Captain America's strength and speed
Generally it seems like it's only meant be temporary.
And I don't know what the cooldown is on the ability.
It seems like there's a pretty big cooldown.
She ends up using her power
to take Kingpin back into his memories of his father
beating his mother, other memories of violence
that they shared together.
To her credit, she does try to help him
get past those traumatic memories,
which it seems like he cannot like.
He's just so messed up in the head that he takes off.
Like, that's it. I've had enough of this.
what if there was any confusion?
It does seem like he forgives
Echo for what she did trying to kill him.
So it's not like he's going to try and kill her
or force her to come back.
Now, he's basically just made his peace
with the fact that she's never coming back.
turned his mind on to other things, which will get to
you in a second because of the post-credits scene
they essentially in the series with her
having a fast and furious style family dinner like post
all of the Fast and Furious means it's all about
family is almost exact way, though.
The Fast and the Furious movies end they have a special
thank you card
from Marvel to the Choctaw Nation, who worked with them
in real life to make it as accurate
as possible to their history,
their culture, during the Post-Credits scene, Kingpin
turns this tension from echo to his real war battles,
like taking of his empire.
when he orders the meeting of the remaining heads
of all the crime families in New York working for him,
essentially all of his other bosses, the situation
that he's worried about,
in danger of spiraling out of control
is all the fallout that's been happening
to the organization in the wake of the Hawkeye Series,
especially Echo blowing up all the weapons
and I also think this is supposed to have something
to do with the events of the secret invasion series.
Generally, things in America,
at least in this part of the world,
are starting to spiral out of control just in general,
not just in Kingpin's purview in New York City.
But while he's ordering that meeting,
he sees the broadcasts about the upcoming race
for mayor of New York City
and is inspired to run when the broadcasters say
that there's no strong candidate
like it needs to be somebody who's a brawler,
who's not a career politician
and not afraid to fight with them.
making a lot of daredevil references.
Also in the comics, Kingpin is also a prize fighter,
just like Daredevil was.
the whole idea is they're going to be adapting
the mayor kingpin storyline from the comics.
In fact they already filmed a lot of that storyline
last year for Daredevil Born Again.
But then Kevin Biggie canceled
all those episodes, kind of restarted
the series, hired a bunch of the Punisher writers
and the Loki writers to redo Daredevil, Born again.
already did a much longer video in the Post-Credits
scene talking about how this sets up
Daredevil Born Again Other Marvel Netflix
defenders characters that might show up during that.
Some of this could change because they just started
filming again in There are going to be 18
episodes total.
I don't know if there are any plans
to bring Echo back on the live action series.
I'm sure somewhere she will come back,
but I don't know if she's going to appear in
any of the upcoming movies at any point,
is there any really big Easter eggs or connections
to other series that you spotted
that I didn't talk about in the video, just write them
below in the comments
and I'll do more videos for Daredevil Born Again
As we get more footage,
click here for that full Daredevil born again
teaser and click here for that brand new Deadpool
3 teaser trailer.
Thank you so much for watching
and I'll see you guys in the next one!